hey everyone it's Tom here we're here
for the final ever well the final
episode of the show but the reason we're
all here the reason me and death it's
literally taken us a year to get to this
point of going through all 12 issues of
watchmen today we are going over the
final issue you're listening to watching
The Watchmen if you enjoy the show
please email us we've got two great
emails to get through today watching a
watchman pod at gmail.com subscribe to a
channel where this is hosted comment
below share get in touch with us all
those sort of stuff but um you know it's
not just me the the pale to my horse
deaf how's it going hello Tom how you
doin
it's crazy isn't it that we're finally
here it's remarkable so much has changed
yeah you've got married from us doing
the first issue to this one yeah the
thing that they have since we started
I've lost two grandparents got married
we changed my job just became a
worldwide sensation as well thank you
stop Tom thank you thank you I'll be I'm
minor bye-bye appreciate it and you know
everyone aware for all our to listeners
thank you Eric and and David for
listening we are a watchman pod you know
going through issue by issue and let's
just let's get stuck into it then I was
gonna say to me you're talking about the
to listeners actually went to a gig at
the weekend and two of the people I got
talking to they're totally unrelated to
each other they both said they listen to
the podcast I loved it yeah quite quite
a good little thing that's crazy okay
that's like it's pretty cool yeah I
always always give you a shout out I
actually haven't heard it yet but I did
an episode on the don't flop title
matches and we discuss you versus Tony
and I wasn't too complimentary actually
but I did make sure we didn't watch my
podcast and carmine curve gave a little
I'm not always mention it and no one
really knows all the four gates but
that's what's great about it it's a
little niche it's a brilliant in we can
we can celebrate and yeah issue 12 the
final issue we begin you know in media
as really the consequence of Ozzy doing
it you know half an hour or so before
the the squid implosion has happened and
kickoff as we always do with the first
panel love the the gluttonous dripping
of blood here reminded me a little bit
across the clock face of the issue to
the front to issue to which you can
remember is kind of Lady Liberty and
just the I guess the detail of the the
viscosity is what made me notice that
yeah it's it's really well done
obviously it's a yellow clock at
midnight with blood gushing down it this
is an allusion to the Doomsday Clock
being at midnight finally and they're
little the yellow teardrop of blood that
we've seen on the the yellow sari the
little red teardrop of blood that we've
seen on the yellow smiley face
throughout the entirety of Watchmen it's
now gushing with blood against it and
it's just an incredible opener really
especially with just how much it ties
into everything that's preceded it and
it's really really well done the blood a
love out John Higgins friend of the
podcast as colored it to have little
white reflective points in it and it's
expertly done there's a nice gradient to
color from the dark yellow at the bottom
of the page up to the light at the top
really well done especially for the time
that it was released and it just brings
that cover to life more than anything
ironically yeah he totally does yeah the
splashes on the rims there's just
something so totemic so final about this
not only we are bringing the whole hour
to the close the numerals as well which
just you know gives a sense of sort of
reckoning of rapture and I do know about
you maybe my eyes are playing tricks on
me but obviously it's not quite it's
just on the cusp of hitting midnight and
then when we get to the first panel it
looks like it's completely hit midnight
which I guess is sort of a you know an
allusion to the fact that life does go
on like you know there is going to be
some progression some momentum ear
despite the horrific levels of death
that we encounter in these opening pages
yeah it's really nice
it's you taking place basically you
following the camera as it moves through
Madison Square Garden which is just
piled with bodies and I like that they
let you know that it's a sold-out event
here as it shows you that there must
have been thousands of 1000 people
thousands of people there to sell out
Madison Square Garden and it's a pale
horse concert it is who I'm sure you
know loads about them Tom being a big
heavy metal but yeah yeah yeah I mean
the illusions as well that the pale
horse rider one of the four horsemen and
you know I remember like when I first
read this like a lot of this stuff we
always says we sort of breezed past they
didn't really pay attention but there's
loads of little things here I think
especially I really like the top window
at the left that isn't smashed it's only
smash kind of against the ear of the
corpse so you can just sort of pull the
cross glazed over and then I mean you
can just you can spend hours looking at
all the faces I mean Dave Gibbons is a
master of just canoing these gruesome
like just the way they're hanging over a
lot of them are skewered on glass as
well from the pain and I love how one of
them's holding a knife as well and that
kind of shows to me that these people
were close to tearing each other apart
anyway so maybe Ozzy man dies his plan
was justified in a way and but yeah it's
just one hell of an opener really not
many comic books especially at the time
opened on basically genocide no it's
just very impactful it really is it's
just that the surplus of of you know of
death here that's kind of overwhelming
and seeing all these people a lot of
them have eyes open and you can you know
you can look into the back and you can
see people slowly degradation into spots
into nothingness and watchman's such a
tight comic there's so many panels on
each page there I love how it just comes
to this final flourish where it's
literally there's there's no paneling at
all we're just getting these
uninterrupted view you know for instance
page two and three is like and you know
four and five or just cross pages either
themselves and you can pour over them
but looking old Where's Wally or
something there's so much to see yeah I
mean
questions going straight though yeah
this is satellite on the roof that looks
like it smiley face do you know if Alan
Moya was a fan of pale horse or to be
hate them because you can kind of take
this either way yeah I'm pretty sure
pale horse are fictional
right okay yeah Google day it's the
first thing I've actually googled on the
podcast Tom to say yeah to see if there
were a real band in the work yeah it
looks like they're a band that formed in
the 2000s so there's some sort of like
pop punk band
I like how before when I mentioned that
you would know who they were being a
heavy metal fan you just kind of pass it
off when you did Tom I didn't know if
they were all knowing that entire
podcast Tom's coming out in the 12th and
do not tell me that you've been doing it
and you know panning on the second page
as we move back as well obviously
there's a newspapers there there's
people hanging outside of buildings and
probably most notably is the the giant
tentacle right that splayed across yeah
I've just actually googled it like you
Tom and there was a pale horses was an
album by a band called me without you
and had it's song called Chernobyl as
well yes me without you I genuinely love
like they're a great band
yeah I'm strange because I've just made
that up this is a song called Chernobyl
1985
yes which might tie in of this are we
Richard a big we are reaching because I
mean they formed in 2000 again Allen war
might be into them they're they're
they're they're a great [ __ ] oh this
is it this is a 1-up maybe they're not
you know if I threw it off anyway Tom
back to what can we start again please
the squid the squid squid the vagina
squid look at the corpses as well we see
that got the watch peddler at the bottom
of page free which is great you know
more kind of like David Simon in the
wire has spent the whole series teaching
you how to actually read this thing you
know what you look for and it even The
Day the Earth Stood Still
which which is a real film and is pretty
relevant to these proceedings
what's about an alien invasion
yeah isn't that Tom and it's about The
Day the Earth Stood Still which version
do you prefer the original 1951 film or
the Keanu Reeves version Tom I haven't
seen my younger brother sing at the
cinema when he was like 16 and like
hating it I think I think he despised it
but yeah I'm seeing it myself
no I love Keano he's the nicest guy in
Hollywood he's ago yeah I think yeah
speed genius matrix
I love the majors but I think speed is
just the the the all-time greatest idea
for an action film yeah it's the
ultimate can see a car chase and it
ticking time bomb and the same thing
isn't it Dennis Hopper as a slighted
police chief as the Wilier rich
Christopher Christopher Nolan said that
the reason he ended the Dark Knight
Rises on a car chase with a ticking time
bomb and was just because he loved those
motifs in film but speed did it first
speed lead if a speed has that beautiful
moment when Sandra Bullock's driving but
she doesn't have a license why don't you
have a license
speeding oh [ __ ] maybe a maybe speed
podcast is in the offing minute by
minute one of those Deep Ones like [ __ ]
for Goodfellas we've got something we
need a cover after this Tom because this
is the last issue and I don't think
they'll ever bring it back half in the
[ __ ] ruined it and check out our
doomsday yeah yeah yeah I'm still going
and then on two four and five as well so
many things we're seeing we're seeing
Ganga dyno seeing you know the
Promethean cab rank we're seeing
Reggie's parents on on the sidewalk yeah
I like how he's got a briefcase there
and there's Rorschach sketches scrawled
out on the floor there's the Veidt
methods blowing in the street there's
also I caught this one Tom there's a
little bin there mm-hmm or a trash can
for our American friends like a bin lid
with the yellow plug socket on it and
there's a blood splash near the little
plug socket and so again
follows the the smiley face motif with
the the little drip of blood P on down
yeah yeah again just a level of details
incredible even like the the news vendor
guy cover covering up the the comic book
reader oh the corpse still smoking yeah
yeah and I love the void method I will
give you bodies beyond your wildest
imaginings genius because parties is
obviously a battle rap related term
buddies it just basically means that you
did piling up the bodies a bit
now here's what I didn't catch shifting
Alan Moore invented that term I think
Alan Moore invented but bow rap I
thought he was I wonder what you think
of Bauer I actually did do a lot of
spoken word stuff and his knowing him
art scene but yeah I think it would be
slightly below him so you know I we try
and sound educated on this show distinct
but I do like going on the annotate
watchman websites and seeing what people
wrote about now I I didn't catch this at
all I just read this in the last half
hour or so page 6 so when we get the
final splay of the squid they're
basically saying and I can definitely
see it his goo that's running down the
Institute for spatial studies X ratio
this is all all die and you can actually
see the the L on the yellow paper as
well next to the Al Wow yeah so
basically if you don't have the book in
front of you and the aliens perched on
top of a monument and it's blood
stripping down and it's covering up
certain that as you can just very
briefly see that the faint I don't lie
in the faint and I none of them ever
just as a [ __ ] all died yeah yeah I
love that I think there's remember
exactly but it's one of the issues
that's like the radioactive hazmat sign
that has something similar where the
smoke is kind of spelling out another
word so more has done that before and I
look at the creature itself let's
discuss it as I'm briefly yeah you know
what I was gonna say it's very dated but
I think it's on purpose and because if
you watch like monster alien invasion
movies of the the 60s and 70s a lot of
the aliens in them were like this yet
very much a war of the worlds' day of
the Triffids just massive tentacles huge
eyes and yeah it fits in with the
aesthetic of watching them quite nicely
I think because Watchmen is obviously a
deconstruction of pop culture just as
much as it is of comics and it's just
nice that that they have like this big
thing that people would be used to
seeing on tell you all the time that
just sprawled out in the city and people
would think that worst fears had come
true and say yeah it's really really
good yeah this is the apotheosis of the
movie monster definitely and yeah it's
issue-free the judge of all of us talked
about before where it says fallout
shelter but it looks like all-out hell
yeah more clearly having a lot of fun
with those sort of times 7 Olaf he he is
our life and David Wang our first email
very brief email from David thank you so
much David for emailing throughout the
run it's a great insight he just says do
you think the not top gang that killed
Hollis Mason was destroyed by adrian
veidt's grand endgame my black shriveled
cynic heart needs to know it sincerely
David I think there were and if you look
in the pale horse concept that is a lot
of top hats there there I am one of the
guys who's holding and knife is there
and so I think they got the gist deserts
in the end especially at the bottom near
the sign there's quite clearly four or
five top not people yeah yeah yeah and
it was there Tom it was it was them they
did it is if to compound this sense of
escalation the first word spoken is
midnight as as John is reading the paper
lorries crying we see the skull around
her neck as well which has kind of
emphasizes the you know on the present
nature of death and this must be quite a
fun thing for John he says you know I'd
almost forgotten the excitement of not
knowing is he is it tacky ins is it
tacky or I don't how to pronounce it
tacky ins and so basically I haven't I
don't know if a definite but I'm pretty
sure that the little elements or atoms
that can disappear and reappear at
random
so scientists believe that they are
actually traveling through time yeah and
that don't know if that's right or not
so right in
well not we'll never read the email out
but just just to make yourself feel
better like you know something more yeah
right in what it is yeah it's a
hypothetical particle that travels
faster than lie most physicists believe
that faster-than-light particles cannot
exist because they're not consistent
with the laws of known laws of physics
obviously dr. Manhattan isn't either
and yet it comes from a sheet a key
which means Swift okay which is quite
interesting but yeah we see the harush
him a couple times I wasn't really right
was a well I mean you're in the right
ballpark yeah you're right I was
actually let's also don't email in I've
saved you five minutes listeners and you
know Laurie trying to bring humanity
into it they only wanted Indian food
really and they've gotten a lot more on
their plate and you view this just kind
of illustrates isn't the divided yet
again between the copper where Laurie
understandably is breaking down and I
like the movement here as well there's a
lot of things that John isn't noticing
because of the tachyons or whatever and
he doesn't quite catch nadi needs to
really for the story but that Lauri's
pocket in the gun i didn't even realize
that yeah she owes it in the third panel
year and he just yeah of course cuz cuz
she shoots yeah how would she have
gotten that gun yeah really nice detail
no no I didn't either until the Reid
fruit but yeah he'd never question
because she never had a gun before so
yeah that's that's where she gets robbed
you know Manhattan explaining a lot
about you know why he hasn't been able
to understand this thing him sensing
Antarctica kind of finding out the
hidden base and yeah but yeah come back
to the two divides between them I think
basically she's really stressed out
whereas John's more he's sort of
analyzing the scene like like almost
forensic ly I mean he's tracing the
signal back so he's looking at it very
detached emotionally in order to get to
the root of the problem where she's just
the complete opposite and John himself
sort of goes on an arc in this issue
and and he does grow in certain ways but
this is definitely I think the coldest
that he's been in the entire run yeah it
doesn't seem that bothered by it no no
or all Lori's reaction to it either and
we we get back then to Karnak and all
these sequences are so good as see as he
loved this I think this the story's
gotten to its ending so skillfully and
it's so satisfying to see everything
play out in this in this manner and the
slow realization really from Rorschach
and night owl from issue 11 that he's
gone and done it death yeah well dan
doesn't really believe that as Yemen
dies has done it which I think saw the
metaphor for those who blindly follow
and believe the government and like like
9/11 and a lot of people think it was a
false flag attack but then there's a lot
of people who think it's too evil for
the government to actually ever do to
their own citizens and these kind of
both show the sides that would happen in
such an event where you've got the
conspiracy theorists and you've got the
people who just believe it completely
and like Alex Jones gets in trouble all
the time for saying massacres are
orchestrated by the government and stuff
like that and it's great just that
there's this sort of the yin and yang
almost of the debate within these two
characters but as human dies is just
basically just standing there smiling
admitting that he's done it yeah and the
lingering blue light as well as it as a
teaser of who's soon to arrive the
polished floors as well just seeing
beneath them it's just you know
marvelous to see this Empire constructed
and yet yeah it like you say Dan kind of
doesn't want to believe is kind of
incredulous in this moment but you know
slowly they all come to understand and
we get a lot of great accomplishments
happen and why exactly needed to go down
and I love the idea of incorporating the
the psychics brain into it
to essentia send people one even there
you know this signal cause let's think
about 9/11 for example which is the most
comparable thing to the squid attack you
know we were both quite young when it
happened I was in primary school when it
happened but you know you can only
imagine at the time being able to fully
comprehend it but still it's a you know
it's an American incident it's kind of
over there you can catalog it to a
certain extent but here ozzie despite
being in New York he's infiltrating the
global consciousness with these images
you know really affecting them in a
profound way yeah he has to really
because a lot of people probably
wouldn't care that much if that was just
happening it in New York and then
basically what he's done is I'll try to
take notes and I don't know if this is
100% accurate but he's cloned the brain
of a deceased psychic and enlarged and
it filled it with terrible information
of an alien world from Mack Shay's book
and the higher manages images and and
he's basically teleported this to
explode on arrival in Times Madison
Square Garden so right that's it that's
all yeah yeah yeah and he taught me t8u
does mention how many psychics
sensitives would have nightmares because
of it and for years to come and this
would kind of enforced the fact that it
was an alien invasion and it's a good
thing though that this entire plan tom
it was actually completely pointless in
the long run because Doomsday Clock they
kind of discovered a lie and then do
nothing to follow it up
yeah and they actually they actually
basically bring that plot point up and
then just drop it and go to another
dimension so no one really has to deal
with the consequences of it Tom but yeah
I definitely think Doomsday Clock
deserves a solid ten outta ten for it's
incredible right and go listen to our
breakdown of doom sake what guys oh you
haven't already oh my god yeah the
marionette origin oh wow wow that is
wicked vision that's gonna warm me for
the rest of my life he also mentions
yeah he says hero manages images Lynette
Paley
sounds I don't remember Lynette Paley
being referenced at all in Watchmen I'm
sure I've missed it because obviously
more would have done
maybe it's in some back matter or
something or a lot of surprises didn't
Google at Tom and dried pass it off with
you as if he knew exactly what page it
was on you [ __ ] but Ivan being the
new frontiersman there is a match a
missing writer missing so yeah it all
comes together beautifully and again
it's more kind of indulging that
stereotype of the villain explaining
their plan but in this case you know
he's not putting her foot wrong he's not
letting you do anything against it like
you know he's done it we arrived back in
the Antarctic
you know white screens are ever-present
and I guess we get the you mentioned the
growth of John and that's totally true
and I guess we see a little growth here
where he immediately in dows Laurie with
the oxygen field Robin on Mars yeah so
he's considering her feelings straight
away from the off which is really good
so he's starting to slowly grow and if
you know this is skin tone as well
darkens quite a bit and which might show
that he's slightly becoming a less of an
illuminant being and he's becoming more
down to earth almost and so yeah it's
it's just little subtle things like the
coloring and you know just nice little
touches out let you know he's slowly
becoming more and more human and
starting to understand people slightly
more because he's gonna have to deal
with the humanity of this basically
dreadful act that has human dies is
committed you know it's so hard really
and and more does it so brilliantly to
get across what it's like to actually be
dr. Manhattan to be experienced in this
life as a guard on all these multiple
planes and this page 11 and 12 is
nothing short of genius for me in yes
the time zones and the tachyons where
you know I'm talking about he repeats
the same dialogue and it's on the same
panels and he's doing the same stature
like that that's so inspired yeah it's
really really nice move because you get
a highlight of the conversation before
it happens
and you just get the it basically
instantly hammers home that John's
perspective of time to all over the
place he's seeing the past future and
present at the same time as the takin's
are affecting his view one time and it's
sort of letting you know as well I mean
to me it's meant to be building up the
tension that he could finally be
defeated so that when as human dies
atomizes him it might feel like a final
ending I don't know if because I have
the prior knowledge to do it that you
know and know that he's he's not quite
it is not really gonna work it but at
the time reading it might have been like
at the end of the Terminator when and
they burn the the robots skin off and he
slowly starts limping along and he has
malfunctions and stuff like that so you
can see that something's quite off with
them um and maybe if you were reading
this for the first time when he gets
wiped out you might think oh my god
that's the end of them so it's a bit
difficult to judge exactly how how I
would view it myself
my perspectives being changed on it is
well Tom yeah yeah definitely
what do you read of the spread at the
bottom of Laurie silently struggling
against nature she's just really not cut
out for a she I think one of the the
biggest motifs of Watchmen is that these
people are in extreme circumstances that
they're not really called for and Bob
probably dr. Manhattan and Ozymandias
they really do face difficulties when
dealing with these next level things
like even Rorschach himself he's sort of
a he's a vigilante but he's very
street-level
you know he's daredevil basically he can
battle people in New York and take them
down but if something big comes along
like a Thanos or something he's not
gonna get called up to deal with that
you know what I mean and he's been
thrust into this situation where he's
having to deal with the fate of the
world almost and similar to how Lori and
Dan are dealing with it that is
completely out of their depth and I
think that's why dr. Manhattan really
takes the lead in this scenario because
he's the only one who can really do
anything about it like he has the
I'll say on how this argument goes and
everyone else is just completely
helpless yeah and it kind of a bit
stupid really Ozzy's plan as dr.
Manhattan says you know tachyons were
clever but this is stupid
him going into the intrinsic field
displacer the sacrifice of Bubastis oh
no sad arguably one of the saddest
deaths in Watchmen yeah not all the
millions of people Tom know cuz they
were [ __ ] I've seen more people in
New York alike they just walk along the
street the shoulder barge in and they go
hey I'm walking here if movies are to be
believed but this death really just
really impacted me Tom yeah yeah it's a
shame I'm sorry for slacking off New
York people their listeners by the way
if you're from New York
I've just seen so many movies set in New
York where they go hey I'm walking you
yeah yeah I've seen a few of those ones
as well yeah yeah I think that's from
the great [ __ ] originally it Dustin
Hoffman's Tootsie I think that's it but
maybe it's just a stereotype and that's
where I just saw it but yeah we have
these yes it's like the New Yorkers
there though the similar sequence to
when dr. Manhattan was at the the Gila
flats pace it's kind of cooling that
back isn't it where he's kind of in
seize be incinerated but I loved that in
his skull you can see his his logo oh
yeah
that is true yeah I notice that but just
never it never registered with me and I
do like how awesome dies to stop hiding
behind this they like intrinsic field
subtractor it's very much like a sort of
1960s James Bond Lily's control panel
where everything's very clearly labeled
like bomb detonator and their stand
behind screen when I F subtractor is
activated yeah it's great
so just presses the big red button next
lit in trinsic feel subtractor and it
just blows them apart yeah obviously
saying forgive me to pass this but I
guess you could read it to a certain
extent humanity is he saying yeah you
know that he's done this thing I kind of
wanted it does look it does look so
fabulous you don't I think Oh
all humans have a soft spot for animals
like even mass murderers like Buffalo
Bill in Silence of the Lambs he's got a
soft spot for that little puppy doesn't
he and I think people just do they just
care about animals because they're so
lovely and cute they are lovely I mean I
kind of would have liked dr. Manhattan
to rebuild his intrinsic field with
Bubastis DNA and their hybrid like yeah
yeah Wow whatever we should do like a
fan comics shouldn't be blue bestest oh
well every episode that we piled through
this coming it was worth for that one
line they're amazing you know Ozzie says
you know something he wasn't expecting
from behind him comes Laurie with the
gun which we discussed before that she
got um I'm pretty certain her pointing
the gun is similar to the the Vietnamese
woman pointing it a comedian at the
double check but it kind of looks the
same to me like the kind of crying eyes
and the gun pointed forward and you know
he catches the bullet obviously did you
pull it in Doomsday Clock was that much
fun I think did comedian not shoot Adam
or in Lex Luthor sir yeah yeah maybe I
dived out the window or something what
was that about
again that comment right I found the
Vietnamese one and it's not no yeah it's
totally different
she slashes him across yeah you're right
yeah yeah you're right yeah he pulls a
gun yeah oh man what see yeah
all right let me check out the old old
watchman for that but yeah again quite
wordless here um you know her firing is
she that knowledgeable of a gun before
the would that even matter he captures
captures it and I love the paneling at
the top of page 16 the clothes hand the
hand opens the realization what's about
to happen yeah brilliant and the movie
does this really well Paul so it's just
a it's a very nice action
pieces that really highlights how ahead
of everyone in skills awesome and Isis
they just don't stand a chance against
him and he's not even that bothered
about killing them to be honest he sort
of been weighing up this issue exactly
what to do with them and even similar to
the the fight at the dinner table in the
last issue
he's completely outclassing them in
every single aspect they can't even take
him down with the gun and he's gonna
he's just [ __ ] them up Tom yeah I
love the my new world demands less
obvious heroism making your school
yeah heroics redundant yeah and then I
has strutting along his knee and then
who's that at the window it's a 70 foot
tall yeah this panel was especially the
bottom of page 17 that could have been
something from a 1960s Fantastic Four
comic definitely it's it's probably the
most hyper realistic moment in the
entire comic just seeing like this big
hand bursts through a window it kind of
reminds me a bit of King Kong mmm yeah
you see my hand smash through the window
and try and grab someone and then he
struts in giving it the big in like his
big blue dick that is completely cut
from that I kind of would hit that that
in Tom it's got a hanging above the
panel I think yeah I've seen that yeah
it's a shame that I thought he drops one
of the best quotes as well which is
saying the world's smartest man means no
more to me than does it smartest termite
yeah and he goes what's in your hand
fight I don't think he delivers it like
that but I'm gonna you know i'm gonna
get the listeners hyped up for the the
final thing what's in your hand bite
another ultimate weapon and we get an
aerial shot of the squid on one of the
screens as well which is really good to
see it from above and yeah cool to see
all of the new stations reporting on
this from all around the world yeah you
know there's no arguing anymore really
you see all their different faces
reacting Manhattan is stoic we can't
quite believe it
workout Rorschach's paneling at this
point but they're all just obviously a
gas fear of what's going down yeah so
basically whites just turn the TV on as
neat yeah yeah he's just shut them down
with information yeah um our game bytes
not playing by the rules and instead he
shows that he United the world in peace
in order to get John to kind of back off
which is an again that's a nice play by
BIOS human dies that shows he is one
step ahead of everyone else yeah the
crew realization then and there that
they can't reveal the truth you know
it's kind of a yeah a foregone
conclusion ultimately they would they
wouldn't do this which is such a
beautiful rich pain I don't remember
reading this initially and just
pondering that and it it's such a great
quandary you know it's their own Gordian
not really that they get tied in along
with him and yeah again so much dialogue
hey but all the character so interesting
the plot just you just want to know more
and more yeah and I cannot see Doomsday
Clock topping this no ends amazing what
if we have to go back on our word well
if it ends Tom that will be amazing and
for me
bang-bang back yeah so basically they're
stuck in just an unwinnable situation
it's a real catch-22 where they've let
millions of people die and they could
expose the truth but if they do then
they're gonna dam the world to even more
war and destruction and yeah it's just
it's incredible Rorschach won't
compromised and agree to it so he gets
killed for it
yeah and Dan and Laurie Gough and make
love and there's the the nice shot of
the lovers on the wall on the shadows as
they stand in smooch Tom yes yes there
is and yeah I love that I love the them
again in costume the sort of the the
backdrop of Armageddon that they've
appealed to before the wait slit as well
with the pool and the shot of
Rorschach's face just so lovely which I
guess I'm just seeing now in his face
you can kind of see Laurie and Dan can
you the lovers are definitely yeah
100% they're emblazoned across his face
and yeah it's almost sold like a look of
shock on his face I think um it's just
yeah it's just incomplete
I'd like I don't even know where he's
going no he's going up on this little
scooter book he probably knows deep down
that there's nothing that you can really
do about it um he's gonna attempt to
head back to land but like how would he
even get back there yeah yeah cuz it cuz
all came off the high ridge didn't it so
I guess they could get back into arch he
maybe could pilot just notice the dr.
Manhattan steps on a butterfly they came
from the the biodome okay yeah really
good spot yeah quite nice him in kind of
flouncing upon nature but yeah this this
again I think is a really good sequence
in the film I think I think they capture
his death
really really well what's his name
Jackie Earle Haley is that his name yes
it is yeah a really good actor yeah he
knows it as Rorschach you know that was
a really really good one but hey
Rorschach dies he's not gonna compromise
yeah and I remember reading Alan Moore
an interview with him saying that he
halfway through the story he knew that
Rorschach couldn't survive and it really
does speak to his character that he just
wouldn't compromise like you wouldn't
compromise with the Keene act and he
just knows that no matter what he has to
be above the the villains of this world
and and just do the right thing
exposing luck the lies telling the truth
that that's who Rorschach is he doesn't
you know he doesn't do wrongs to make a
right he just is very blunt and the
truth must be told in his eyes yeah yeah
and bloody deaf as well you feel like
Manhattan could just click his fingers
and he disappears but he explodes him
yeah
and in the movie as well they do like a
little Rorschach pattern on the floor
and his blood I think yo I was a nice
touch okay cool
yeah hashtags neither better than more
yeah though they need I mean the same
way that Rob Liefeld every mentions
before that he sold all his stuff to
Netflix wink Mark Miller did as well
it's like if Netflix bought like the
more back catalogue and it's like we're
getting Tom strong we're getting Swamp
Thing we're getting what yet again even
though Damon Lindelof just did it like
you know off happy fire but obviously
that would never ever happen I really
don't know what's gonna happen with his
Watchmen TV show you know yeah I think
it's been picked up for a full season
yeah but I mean like it's not set it's
not using the characters is it it's just
setting the watchman universe well I
don't we'll make a TV show on The
Watchmen a great idea that yeah and by
that I mean not do it about the actual
story do it about something that no one
cares about
it's like prequels Tom it's like a
prequel Tom why why it makes something
that isn't where the actual story is no
no it might be great but it might be I
mean I I started watching the leftovers
that Lindelof show it wasn't bad but I
just knew they had a good ending that's
what I'd been told and I spoiled the
whole thing for me like one episode in
is the ending is pretty good actually
that's right okay watch the rest of it
yeah it you know what it's about you
know like 2% of the world just
disappears one day and like everyone
cope with it but every country loses 2%
in the world so you know someone loses
all their family members there are
cities where no one's been touched and
there's cults that have sprung up the
don't speak and just smoke because they
feel that not raptured and they're
accelerating their death and it's quite
a good world actually I'm I'm getting
you started talking about it but back to
like infinity war isn't it Tom it is in
a sense yeah and one of one of the one
of my little Easter eggs Tom in my
infinity war top amazing things you
missed one of the actresses from the
leftovers is in infinity war so make
sure you subscribe to that video like it
comment it thumbs up it thumbs down it
share it whatever I'm sure you've seen
this on your endless perusing but I saw
someone on reddit refer to fantasies
click as the snap inning
yeah
which chef what was pretty fire nice
reminds me of the fat burning that Tom
oh my god glory days days Supergirl that
was that was one of my finds so I've
never seen it but oh wow ya know wow
it's no cuz I don't want to be a part of
it and I don't want to condone it so
I'll get someone to look on their
computer and I'll lean over and go what
you're looking at oh no what no get it
off because it's a massive breach of
privacy Tom and I'm quite disappointed
in you for saying that you did it I only
seen it because I got innocently passed
it through what's up without asking
right so yeah but you sound like a
[ __ ] pervert I sought it I sought it
and I was I was saying up about shame as
as topped went out and destroys across
the water I think we see the god of
death in the background there and you
mr. bear Tommy gives them a little smile
he does actually yeah he looks like you
when you discovered them pictures like
at all but yeah yeah he's it's nice to
see that he's Connor he's happy for them
he's happy for them
it's is the best moment for him in the
entire comic anything to me even though
he's just murdered one of his friends
yes no yeah and he's not told anyone the
dead either so they continue to think
he's alive yeah maybe that's what he's
laughing about
he knows he's [ __ ] off and he knows
they'll never find out anything to be
read by Laurie spooning dad I don't know
really the mail yeah I just I don't know
whether that quality though yeah cuz
Dan's yeah it is because I guess Dan's
always shown a slightly more OFI perhaps
in those roles but yeah and then we have
a shot maybe it's like signifying that
they're submissive to Ozymandias mm-hmm
and they're just kind of completely
agreat to his plan and they're just
taking it and dance let himself gets big
spooned by a woman dr. Manhattan then is
that sexist I write in and tell people
is it sexist
I'll admit on I've been a little spoon
quite a few times this week
so I'm all for that hashtag me too
is that what me too is about no no no it
that's right yeah but I'm working for
equality here on so I'm still
progressive yeah yeah thank you thank
you Tom
doctor I'm looking forward to that Nobel
Peace Prize stumbling upon Aziz worried
or worried that he said before he said
this earlier on I like to look that word
up it means kind of like a planetarium
as what he's looking at which is Rio and
this whole exchange is beautiful right I
mean it just takes the place over one
page but it kind of sums up so many of
the themes of the whole book it is
beautiful and I'm sure will ruin it
m's well let you talk about it before I
step in and give my terrible opinion on
it well I suppose you know Ozzie
ultimately was looking you know for the
answer but as anyone who's ever tried to
work anything out to any empirical
nature there's you know you never
satisfied ultimately and he's in commune
I with a higher being who can you know
assure him that his plan was wrong but
nothing nothing comes from this you know
nothing ends Adrien nothing ever ends I
suppose and that's what Ozzie was aiming
for you know a finality to this problem
but you know you're just gonna contain
foolish yeah yeah exactly its fruition
you can't really have your will like
Alexander wanted a Empire that span for
thousands of years but it's never gonna
happen like that like it's just
impossible to and so yeah it's it's nice
that this little send-off it just leaves
him a bit worried and but it's true like
you know and John knows that nothing's
gonna ever end which is why goes off on
his own to to create up his own form of
life in his own universe and in his
short he's very much showing that he's a
God in the lead up to this like what
what does oz human dietary what is dr.
Manhattan say earlier in the graphic
novel something about how he doesn't
think God exists and if he did then he's
not sure
he would be anything like him hmm is
that it's something summing those lines
anyway so he denied being a God
basically but in the build-up to this he
shows that years when he walks on water
and many discusses going off to create
life in in a new universe and I'm just
so thought about how you know he walks
past Dan and Laurie and that could
almost be a metaphor for Adam and Eve
and that they're in the Garden of Eden
at the moment that they've gained this
knowledge that's gonna cast them out
into the world and they're gonna have to
deal with the consequences of it and you
know nothing's ever gonna be the same
it's gonna be cold and lonely so maybe
those are like allusions to the Bible or
what not but by the end of this year dr.
Manhattan is 100% of God um yeah and he
disappeared he goes off yeah you think
he goes to create the DC universe Tom I
think yeah I think he goes off to
straight Jeff Jones and that's all
that's just patient zero and he's his
smoke his backwash sort of engulfs this
system of the planets and I was he so
vulnerable here like we've never seen
him for John wait before you leave I did
the right thing didn't I yeah so he
still needs reassurance that in he's
doubting himself yes which is a very
human side to him because throughout
this entire computation he's been very
sort of confident that he is doing the
right thing and it's nice for that to
just all of a sudden be a doubt we move
forward then I guess slightly forward in
time here where the guys are in a sort
of witness relocation program and one of
the things that Eric pointed out we'll
get to his email just into the issue but
one of the things you pointed out that I
thought was very cool was on the mantel
is a cord card which I guess is sort of
signifying like you know the peace
accords that happens so currently and
the fact that that had become a sort of
you know an occasion to celebrate
through cars yes I fall again well
building buy more is out of this world
what your thoughts on this sequence yes
I really like it you know does strongly
peace on earth I was very much a
Christmas motif isn't it like goodwill
to all men and peace on earth and and I
like that Laurie let's so expect a
senior know that she knows who her
father is but that doesn't matter
because like takes us in strange places
and it's a form of acceptance really and
then her and Dan leave and still expect
a senior sits there crying and kisses a
photo of the minutemen hmm and it's it
is a shame because she did love the
comedian even though it was a really
really bad person but he calls back
again to nostalgia and that you can look
back on horrible things remember them
fondly and life is about you know ups
and downs and it's all part of a journey
in the long run that makes you a
stronger person so I think it is it's a
really you know it's a nice moment it's
good character building it is good out
of bad comes good and I suppose for all
the encounters with Eddie you know he
gave her her daughter yeah definitely
and yeah you should always look at you
know the glass is being half full and
it's a great outlook to have and yeah
it's nice and as the as the old
tournament once said times change and
you know this world is moving forward we
see the Hashima lovers being painted
over
symbolically and were basically you know
watching our main guy his name CIPS
online now what's his name Seymour as
they're walking through millennium is
now the yeah which beautifully Ozzie
like you know yeah exactly everyone's
looking forward to the future instead of
looking back on things fondly which is a
much better perspective to have I think
it's pointless trying to look back and
change the past you can only look
towards things and and kind of you know
I mean just always strive to go forward
and what do you mean the released
Doomsday Clock which is a sequel that
does nothing but picks up tiny little
nostalgic bits of the previous work that
was much better Tom [ __ ] sake
this is something that he's stepping on
I've literally just noticed it's now at
the bottom of page 41 see more New York
survivors reveal nightmare I guess that
means under hypnosis yeah so what is
what is that employing them that they
these these memories had to be unlocked
they were so deep maybe yeah maybe they
were repressed yeah yeah but again it
enforces that the lie would be believed
because you know under hypnosis it's
very difficult to lie and I know
hypnosis is a lot of [ __ ] but yeah
just again it enforces these things all
right maybe it maybe he's stepping on
that newspaper because it shows that
people are kind of trying to get over
the wall yes old man yeah yeah exactly
yeah yeah Ronald Reagan to run in 88 no
well I was annoyed about this Tom
because I remembered it it's been Ronald
Reagan and but on page 32 he says Robert
Redford at the taro okay nice and I
remembered it being Ronald Reagan as
well because I had like ages of guys to
Google it to say when this was released
and and if like were knew in advance
that Ronald Reagan was gonna become the
president but I kinda wish that they'd
went back you know and they did the
absolute addition and the reprints of it
and they just changed it but never mind
yeah yeah
never mind and here we have one of the
greatest endings in literature really
for me I think it's absolutely perfect
because it just parches it on that
narrative cliff and you know maybe all
the cards are gonna tumble down or maybe
not really because it's kind of
established that the paper they work for
these guys new friends here's when I
think this Moglen overexpress always get
them mixed up doesn't have too much
influence you know had some influential
readership but maybe it wouldn't got
picked up maybe it will just be excised
and ignored or whatever but still
everything down to the catcher make it
Duvall pan is slowly fascia days hand
reaching forward to Rorschach's journal
just wonderful clothes right perfect
yeah it just really is the perfect
finish for it um just seeing that burger
splash in the smiley face and his jumper
and it to me it hints that this could
all happen all over again and nothing
really ends no and he gets the
opportunity to run with whatever he
wants and he goes for the journal and I
suppose we because we don't get any back
matter at all I suppose it would make
sense maybe we'd have Rorschach's Guiana
but we've kind of had that for a while
and it yeah demean it a little bit
devalue it if we were just to giving it
there and then well if you wanted you
could you know start the book again and
read it as the perspective of the guy
reading Rorschach's Journal yeah yeah
like so again it's a cyclical view of
time that Moore's put in his book yeah
you're right yeah cuz of course what
general does yeah open the entire [ __ ]
you know Wow yeah that is a that's
tripped me out that'sthat's great yeah
deeds and yeah they both oh they both
open with the small he faced the forces
well wanting the gutter one on his shirt
yeah yeah brilliant
perfect Jesus oh it transitions into the
the opener as well it does it yeah it
does it's like should we do this podcast
again yeah yeah let's just let's just go
back let's go maybe listeners you can go
back you can download these episodes and
you can enjoy it as well but I mean
doubt now that was watchman death free
we're finally free Tom man you know
again let us know in the comments what
you for the run what you thought the
episodes thank you to everyone since
silly for listening as well and we've
got any emails I do I do yeah I'd not
forgot sir Eric at all so yeah let's get
into it from Eric he says hello dear
Sirs I want to thank you for a
fascinating ride these past several
months what an amazing job you two did
reviewing the watchman issue-by-issue is
it even possible to spend an hour on any
other normal-sized comic book I doubt it
yeah it's a good point I highly doubt as
Warrick I hope you both were planning on
doing something after this besides
doomsday [ __ ] by all means finish it but
something else besides that so yeah I
mean we were sort of said maybe not for
the time being I'm gonna tackle anything
massive we were gonna do from hell but I
think it'd be best if we just do maybe
you know little bear trades or some ink
for a little while yeah see what we want
to talk about in the future but yeah we
will still got before Watchmen we still
got the yeah we got before which when we
got Doomsday Clock we've got um
Watchmen film and you know we've got I
always want to get my hands on the
role-playing game and just read that
because it because I know that's the
only thing that more did other than
Watchmen and and that that could be
quite interesting as well so yeah we got
we've got some more stuff eric says i
grew up reading comics in 1980s that's
what my heart is as far as that goes I
would hope you do more Allen more stuff
perhaps miracle man yeah I mean we will
do more stuff personally I would like to
do league with strong again Tamar Tom
strong there too my favorite Allen more
stuff like that I've got I've got loads
mister first I need to read I still need
to read the boat Jeffery saga which is
his kind of Coronation Street parody
like it's completely on superhero based
it's like a social kitchen sink yeah
drama comedy whatever so Eric says I
forward right by issue 12 as well as
your review of issue 11 I thought you
could have spent more time and how
Ozymandias got away that 35 minutes to
go its iconic did Watchmen inspired
Incredibles I think so I wouldn't let my
five-year-old twins wear superhero capes
in public due to safety issues thanks to
dollar bills demise as a nice reference
Eric your review on issue 11 was on it
was as usual spot on nice fine on
Kennedy's would have been speech any
quotes a bit of Kennedy's speech which I
love that that was a speech in Dealey
Plaza that he was going to deliver the
watchman speech as we had the phrase the
watchman comes from Moore was inspired
by the Latin phrase which actually
closes issue 12 you didn't just we
didn't focus on I'm not gonna try and
pronounce it Chris custodiet Ipsos
custodes who watches the Watchmen on the
issue 10 you both discussed how well
read more is and how he gets his quotes
nowadays thanks to the internet it's
pretty easy as Jeff John shows us how he
pulls in random clothes quotes back in
the day in the 1980s I bet more will use
Bartlett's book of quotations the best
place to go for inspiring Winston
Churchill quotes before there was an
Internet I always have another issue
lying around you to have a good
chemistry I appreciate deaths deadpan I
also appreciate how def talked about
persistence persistence is something
young people especially need to hear
about but all of us too I've been
working on a comic related project for
some time but have not made much moving
forward in the last year I need to get
going on that
I mean def Eric's comment we've got to
read that right yeah a hundred percent
didn't send it at least yeah
anything done Eric or any ideas we you
know we would love love to see that
after a close reading of issue 12 please
convey to Jeff Jones my apologies about
how I made fun of how included Robert
Redford as president in doomsday [ __ ]
okay yeah forgot to mention that didn't
me but I do remember that now where it
was kind of like a trump grab wasn't it
and if she wanted UN's de clock but he
was actually just referencing the past
that's that's quite nice that I quite
like that that you know I literally
don't I don't know if it's because I
read too many comics or it was just
forgettable for I think it was both but
I do yeah I remember Redford being
mentioned at the end of issue 12 as Eric
says the fact that Redford might run in
1988 is in the news my apologies mr.
Jones but it's probably the only dumb
[ __ ] idea Alan Moore ever had it's
downright Ellen Moorish right right up
there with Tolkien writing a sequel to
Lord of the Rings it's true but dumb
[ __ ] ish I just read I mean try to read
the latest doomsday [ __ ] issue instead I
will just wait for your review better
time spent honestly I'd rather spend my
comic book reading time rereading the
John Byrne Fantastic Four issues are you
familiar with those deaf I'm not heard
of those I'm not no John Byrne okay
maybe it may be a it's good you guys had
mentioned the reference to Tommy
Robinson he's a wanker thanks to my
economist subscription I were passing
familiarity with him so many wankers out
there you also Eric I love Eric salesman
so an interesting points you had
mentioned that Percy Bysshe Shelley was
the father of Mary Shelley that was
actually his wife okay my mistake there
thanks darlin more during my senior year
in high school in British literature
when I had to write a poem about a poet
I chose him and Ozymandias death asked
about good prequels I liked how he broke
down why they sucked because they
occurred right before the story so
what's the point
Roy Thomas's all-star squadron got it
right though and that's about it
The Game of Thrones freak rule probably
sucked two sequels and prequels they
suck I'm now scared of any miracle man
related project outside a Neil Gaiman
finishes his story
they'll probably suck and then Ian sorry
Eric shared some interesting stuff about
issue 12 he spoke about the accord stuff
which I thought was really cool is his
page 29 contains a reference to the
Accord we should want the peace on earth
and especially between the US and the
Soviet Union is called there are even
Accord cards how brilliant is that yeah
I agree also on page 20 on page 29 he
says there's a reference to the outer
limits
which did you know about this death were
apparently more took the idea Bob she
didn't know about it but uh no way yeah
watch too shitload of the Outer Limits
before but I don't think I've seen the
heaven so I literally had like yet like
two years when I was about seventeen and
where I just binge watch and this was
before like Netflix and Amazon Prime but
I just binge watched like The Twilight
Zone in the Outer Limits
I'm just non-stop absolutely loved them
the so good yeah I need to watch more of
them like what a brilliant life yeah
yeah yeah I mean what's the difference
it's our limits more weird it's just a
certain sort of the same yeah it's the
same sure basically yeah but yeah the
concept really so ahead of their time
and it's great how they're all like
one-off episodes yeah so you can watch
one hate it but around the corner this
there's gonna be an amazing one um and
yeah just classic after classic yeah
yeah the ear rod serling what a voice
why gee I remember the episode that [ __ ]
me up as a kid was where this woman's
husband dies she keeps getting phone
calls the middle of night from him yeah
and then she goes to his grave and the
telephone poles in his grave like yeah
brilliant
yeah my favorite one is it's the howling
man and basically this guy gets caught
in a storm and he rocks up to this
castle and filled with monks and
basically they there's a guy in a cell
and they've locked up and the this the
concept is that the monks tell him
knights the devil and do not let him out
of the cell I don't like that guy out
the cell because it's the devil and but
obviously the guys at the the door like
scream and ask him for help go and
they're mad I'm not the devil I'm not
the devil and but I don't want to spoil
it but definitely go check out the
howling man it might even be on YouTube
you know I'll give it a quick look but
absolutely brilliant that's because
that's the the twilight zone is one with
the thing on the side of the plane isn't
it yes do you remember Johnny Bravo yeah
dude yeah yeah yeah the clown on the
flight that's how I knew about it as a
kid like I don't watch that episode then
yeah and then see if any year
but yeah it's been parodied so much yeah
yeah Simpsons used to like how to serve
man and yeah it's alleged the boss isn't
in the Simpsons a gremlin and them
aliens come down and start feeding
people and take them on the spaceship to
eat them and the church is brilliant
yeah the the episode though from the out
limits that I was referring to is called
the architects of fear and yeah I had
actually heard of that so so this is the
the description on Wikipedia which is
very similar to Watchmen certainly the
cold war will lead to mankind's
destruction a cabal of scientists
assorted they must act to save the world
film of a nuclear missile attack with
people running for shelter is showing
before the plot so you know they still
fake something they fake you know kind
of crazy whatever I don't know spaceship
thing and then yeah they they trick the
world for the sense of saving it so yeah
there's no limits episode
hang on let's go back to whatever you
say and I don't think more did take that
no like very very sort of bird's-eye
view level of the plot would be that but
there's just so much other stuff going
on that yeah I don't really I mean how
many how many plot lines can you do that
very famously
someone said that there's only seven
stories in the world yeah so yeah yeah
apparently Eric was saying that after
Alomar learned of the episode and
brought it to my attention they broke on
it and LEM won quit Watchmen because of
it
really yeah apparently so yeah but I
mean I mean Moore's no plagiarist we're
but it's not even enough I mean maybe
it's kind of similar but whatever
Watchmen is overtaking it culturally
also talking about page eight panel
plays a reference to the 1951 film The
Day the Earth Stood Still when alien
visitor from demands peace or
obliteration and Eric also quoting
Laurie here the scene of Laurie's
emotional reaction was so true reminded
me of my shock when the twin towers fell
and she's they saying you know who safe
how could anyone protect themselves
against the world where this happens and
then Manhattan not involved the raashi
mcgoofy is well there's some controversy
the alien vagina of a joiner alien
doesn't work and the movie ending is
better
or have to say that the comic ending
works so well initially only comic book
fans were familiar with the comic and we
all accept aliens as reality in part of
any universe but for a discriminating
cinema public they would not go for that
they don't approach superheroes in the
same way where the [ __ ] aliens come from
is what they would ask it will be too
much for too many questions within there
and then Eric saying thanks again cheers
Eric thank you genuinely these emails
have been a highlight throughout the
show really appreciate you listening and
like yeah we've only really had one
email half per episode but I tell you
what they've been some absolutely
amazing mails Eric so thank you couldn't
have had a better email we really
couldn't we couldn't had a constant
listener like yourself and happy novice
as well I mean you just made them up Tom
Zarek and yeah we will be back of course
in the future well we better be Tom
because I've ordered the 4k ultimate
cook watchman so and then for Kay's you
know I hire by a player for it Tom and
they're not bloody cheap so we'll be
back we will be back through [ __ ]
doomsday [ __ ] so it's gonna be a while
let us know what you wanted to discuss
in the future and we'll be doing before
watching as well I think we before watch
money might be best if we just go trade
by trade it's like because otherwise a
episodes and it could be for you no I
mean yeah yeah and like they just don't
demand as much attention I don't think
really narrative Lee and I mean some of
them were alright like I like the dollar
bill one shop I remember reading that
Ozzy warm and it was like he had a
girlfriend and she died and that's why
and it's like ah it's his self
motivation that was so inspiring but
yeah completely unnecessary completely
unnecessary but Watchmen remains you
know one of the ultimate things for me
in terms of culture in terms of writing
I return to it every year and DEF it's
been great spending these last this last
year
you talked about this book were fired
were up to have had way downs that I
don't know what the hell knows Alan
we're impressions were about so I'd like
to publicly apologize for those without
John Higgins get involved hopefully you
know we'll get some other other
creatives involved in it in the future
it's up to me really it Todd Muni to
start email and let's really pull your
finger out and email these people John
Higgins interview man that was [ __ ]
great when was that I was like March or
something like yeah yeah yeah that was a
really really good treat so if you
haven't heard that before yeah the first
and March that got uploaded so yeah if
you haven't heard that before
definitely go back with me and deaf
speak to the legend that is John Higgins
who who college watchman and you know
did a lot more than that 566 views not
bad you know but you know needs to be a
little bit better so check it out but
yeah subscribe to the channel check me
out as well if you like Bauer rap batter
out resume is there if you like
Metallica as well as a podcast called
alphabet' aleca with me and guess go
through every single song of the band in
alphabetical order
there is one episode where had a nine
year old boy on it's one of the most
awkward things ever lasting yeah I know
how did you organize that you do realize
if you send more than two messages to
someone under the age of 16 its clusters
grooming don't you Tom well he's dad
organized and that sounds even worse but
right so yeah go check out my episode
worry Liam the heavy-metal kid he's like
this vlog over Chad to Liam he's easy
he's a young boy it's Liam it was it was
awkward as [ __ ]
Geoff what about yourself and I'm just
doing I'm just plugging away Tom you
know I dropped a God of War review a day
it's just about a hit a thousand views
so happy with that make sure you checked
out also shrugged am crazy rich Asians
I was credit scene explained in bracket
who is the mystery man so yeah that's
picking up steam as well 13,000 views
Tom so you know I am the sell-out
I've got no integrity but it's doing
alright for me in it yeah I did some I
did some voiceover work for Big Brother
as well oh yeah yeah yeah saw that that
was sick weird yeah that
it's just keep it just keeps growing and
you know what Tom you're very lucky that
you got in at the ground level on this
because tell you what I wouldn't be
putting up with your [ __ ] all that ice
and no I know what you're like you're
googling stuff I do Google I do Google
but I want to share it with the
listeners and you know again it's not
like I've ever googled anything I did it
from Wikipedia and just read it out in a
video Tom but you know perish perish the
wall gotta make a living but yeah I
guess for the final time on this
original watchman one that's hard say
Watchmen run yeah it's a good night from
me yeah I forgot I forgot what it went
like then yet it's a good night it's a
good matter well obviously let's do it
one more time okay listeners thank you
very much for checking out the last
twelve episodes of watching The Watchmen
it's a good night from me it's a good
night from could get away from me come
back I said good night everyone and
every like you can't see a listeners
book we're all just standing waving as
the credits roll
[Music]